hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are gonna be unboxing the new
samsung galaxy s 8 plus and the Samsung
Galaxy s8 now I made in a previous video
I did a super fun event in New York with
Samsung and they were like guys we're
gonna be sending us eights so be on the
lookout and mine has finally arrived
this one's actually for my sister so
hopefully she doesn't mind that I'm
gonna be unboxing it for her they also
sent their 360 camera which I am so
excited to try I'm actually gonna charge
this we're gonna do with the s8 plus
first I'm a huge fan of having bigger
screens so this is some time into can
wait I was like wait it can wait - what
this is a very good note - to everyone
it can wait distracted driving is never
okay it's so true I got the black one oh
it's beautiful beautiful black looks
basically just like my jet-black iPhone
which is fantastic you guys are gonna
get along great oh we've got a SIM card
but I have a SIM card already
I'll be swapping that out with my Google
pixel what's in here oh yes I need this
I need this very very important anyone
you might not yet don't need that got
the power brick oh we've got a USB USB C
converter oh and a USB micro USB C
converter thanks for being so
considerate these are the AKG headphones
I'm super excited to try these out
because they were definitely hyping them
up in the announcements I love this
material it's kind of like the I guess
it's kind of like a cord it's like a
braided kind of nylon it feels like
mmm and they're super long do you have a
left and a right so that I know they're
actually really comfortable they fit in
my ear perfectly usually when I smile
with my ear pods they fall out I'm into
that
I like these already anything else in
there I should be aware of oh gosh that
is just that's excellent what's this
little sticker why would you put the
sticker right there like don't do that I
don't like that it's so tall how would
you put a sticker on here this is so
silly
like get off of here not gonna scrape it
off and it's leaving a residue No
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're size comparison you can
definitely tell that the SI is slightly
taller than a pixel salts of a little
bit thinner working on it summer ball
huh I'm so sure him so fit there's a lot
of stuff to do
there's face recognition fingerprint
scanner iris scanner pin pattern or
password
yeah I'll turn on interactive customized
experiences multiverse Amazon express
yourself adding a profile picture it's
like a bad passport / bug show get ready
unlock your phone by showing your face
remember to help setup face recognition
indoors or away from direct sunlight
alright hold your phone 18 to 20 inches
from your face position your face in the
circle shown on the screen your face has
been registered turn on face and lock
turn on time to scan your finger I keep
missing the whole screen even feel like
if I try to unlock it with this one the
placement of my thumb hits the bixby
button so one of the huge complaints
that I saw people talking about is the
fact that you can't remap the bixby
button to Google assistant since I don't
really use Android that often I do use
Google assistant which does work quite
well on the Google pixel phone and I use
the Google assistant in Google home
i OS and iPhone is still my main phone
of choice well that being said I don't
really know where I'm going with that
hello Bixby is not set up yet I guess
that's where I was going oh well video
answer this function has the image
quality inner videos yes let's turn it
on baby so the line is interesting is
you know most phones or have a 16 by 9
aspect ratio but this is a little bit
taller you should have been a baller
shot caller crop to fit are you not
doing it
[Music]
there it is this is the full screen
experience baby and I should watch it
look more of a high quality video that's
not something Forte so it looks really
good
let's do a quick size comparison between
the S 8 plus 7 plus and low pixel
[Music]
easy
I will have a separate video talking
about the photo quality in the video I
also have a gear vr which I'm super
excited to try out with the 360 camera
so that's gonna be super fun so stay
tuned for that slap it on least this is
the 360 camera this is the brand new
version so it's a little bit different
than the previous one so this is the
previous version of the Samsung 360
camera and it's much larger than the
newer version which is kind of
incredible I love this little tripod so
I'm gonna take this off and put it on my
new one for sure so my question to you
guys is what phones you currently have
what phone is on your wish list are you
waiting for the new iPhone or any new
announcements to come out about the new
iPhone or are you super into the Samsung
s8 are you gonna get it do you like it
what do you think leave your comments
below and I look forward to reading
those and chatting with you guys in the
comments
[Music]